AND THE BIRTH OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, THAT’S THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE, THE
GOVERNMENT AGAIN RUNS OUT OF
CASH TOMORROW.
UNLESS THE SENATE VOTES FOR A
TEMPORARY SPENDING BILL TO KEEP
THE GOVERNMENT OPEN, ALL BUT
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES
WILL BE SHUT DOWN MIDNIGHT
FRIDAY.
DEMOCRATS AND A FEW GOOFBALL
REPUBLICANS HAVE DECIDED TO HOLD
THE ENTIRE FUNDING OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT HOSTAGE FOR A DEAL TO
GIVE LEGAL STATUS TO 800,000
ILLEGAL ALIENS BROUGHT HERE AS
MINORS.
YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ELECTED TO
REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF
AMERICANS AND UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES HAVE NOW FULLY
EXPOSED THEMSELVES AS NOTHING
MORE THAN A PERMANENT LOBBY FOR
OPEN BORDERS AND UNENDING CHEAP
LABOR.
IT IS A TOTAL TRAVESTY.
THE PRESIDENT -- DESPITE NOT
HAVING CAMPAIGNED ON GIVING
AMNESTY TO ANYONE -- IS WILLING
TO DO A DEAL TO HELP THE DACA
PEOPLE.
BUT HE REQUIRED A FEW BASIC
CONCESSIONS FROM THE PARTY OUT
OF POWER LIKE ENDING CHAIN
MIGRATION AND THE VISA LOTTERY
AND DEFUNDING THE WALL THAT HE
PROMISED TO BUILD.
DEMOCRATS, NOT THE PRESIDENT,
WALKED AWAY FROM THE BARGAINING
TABLE IN AN ATTEMPT TO FORCE HIS
HAND.
I’M THINKING ABOUT THIS TODAY --
DO YOU REMEMBER WHO WAS BLAMED
BY THE MEDIA BACK IN 2013 WHEN A
FEW CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS,
THEY WERE THE PARTY OUT OF POWER
FORCED A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN?
IT WAS ABOUT OBAMACARE.
THE MEDIA AND THE PARTY IN POWER
THAN UNANIMOUSLY BLAMED
REPUBLICANS.
>> THE RESIDENT DREW A FIRM LINE
THAT HE WILL NEGOTIATE BUT HE’S
NOT GOING TO DO IT UNTIL AFTER
HE GETS BOTH A CLEAN CR THAT
EXTENDS GOVERNMENT FUNDING AND
RAISES THE DEBT LIMIT.
>> I’M AFRAID THEY ARE GOING TO
SEND US RIGHT OVER THE CLIFF.
>> WERE NOT NEGOTIATING WITH
PEOPLE WITH A BOMB STRAPPED TO
THEIR CHEST.
>> Laura: THEY WERE FOLLOWING
THE NARRATIVE SET BY THE HEAD OF
THE PARTY IN POWER,
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION IN
WHICH A FACTION IS WILLING
POTENTIALLY TO DEFAULT ON U.S.
GOVERNMENT OBLIGATIONS, THEN WE
ARE IN TROUBLE.
IF THEY ARE WILLING TO DO IT
NOW, THEY WILL BE WILLING TO DO
IT LATER.
>> Laura: A FACTION, IT WAS A
FACTION.
WE HAVE A FACTION NOW, IT TURNS
OUT THAT REPUBLICANS WEREN’T
REALLY HURT ALL THAT MUCH IN THE
2014 MIDTERMS AS MANY PREDICTED.
THE ONLY THING MOST PEOPLE
REMEMBERED ABOUT THE TED CRUZ
FILIBUSTER WAS THIS.
>> I LIKE GREEN EGGS AND HAM, I
DO.
I LIKE THEM, SAM I M.
>> Laura: I SOMETIMES PLAY
THAT TO MY KIDS TO GET THEM TO
SLEEP.
DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING WITH FIRE
AND WE ARE SEEING A LITTLE
MOVEMENT TONIGHT BY
CHUCK SCHUMER, WE WILL GET TO
THAT IN JUST A MOMENT.
A NEW CBS POLL SHOWS THAT EVEN
AMONG THOSE WHO SUPPORT HELPING
THE DACA OF FOLKS, AMERICANS DO
NOT WANT TO SHUT THE GOVERNMENT
DOWN TO DO SO.
BY THE WAY, EVEN WITH ALL THE
MEDIA DISINFORMATION OUT THERE
ABOUT WHAT CHAIN MIGRATION IS,
MORE AMERICANS THINK IMMIGRATION
SHOULD BE BASED ON MERIT.
MORE THAN FAMILY TIES RIGHT
SECOND COUSIN TWICE REMOVED, YOU
KNOW THE DRILL.
ALL OF THAT IS GOOD NEWS FOR
TRUMP.
YOU KNOW WHAT I SAY?
I SAY IT’S TIME TO CALL THEIR
BLUFF.
REPUBLICANS SHOULDN’T BE COWED
AT ALL.
I SAY LET THE DEMOCRATS TAKE
THEIR STAND AND FORCE A SHUTDOWN
OF THE GOVERNMENT FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THEN THE AMERICAN VOTERS WILL
FINALLY SEE ONCE AND FOR ALL
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS AND AMNESTY
FANATICS REALLY THINK -- THE
HOPES AND WELL BEING AND OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS JUST AREN’T AS
IMPORTANT AS THE POTENTIAL VOTES
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO GET BY AN
INFLUX OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
SPEAKING OF EXPOSING THE TRUTH,
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE HAVE
FINALLY SEEN THE CONTENT OF THAT
HOUSE INTEL REPORT ON THE
FUSION GPS DOSSIER AND THE MOLAR
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
AND APPARENTLY IT IS A
BLOCKBUSTER.
SOURCES ARE TELLING
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" THAT THE
CONTENTS PAINT A DISTURBING
PICTURE OF MISDEEDS AND
CORRUPTION INSIDE OF THE OBAMA
FBI WHICH RUNS STRAIGHT INTO THE
HEART OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL’S
OFFICE.
AS OF NOW, THE REPORT IS SECRET
BUT MANY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
ASKING THE SPEAKER TO MOVE TO
DECLASSIFY THE DOCUMENT AND
RELEASE ITS CONTENTS.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE MEMO THAT WE
HAVE JUST READ IS SO ALARMING
THAT IT MUST BE IMMEDIATELY
DISCLOSED TO THE AMERICAN PEOPL
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: I COULDN’T AGREE
MORE, SPEAKER RYAN SHOULD CUT
THROUGH WHATEVER BUREAUCRATIC
PROTOCOL IS NECESSARY TO SEE
THAT THE CONTENTS OF THIS REPORT
IS MADE PUBLIC.
LET’S REMOVE ALL DOUBT ABOUT
WHAT IS IN THAT REPORT.
I’LL TELL YOU THIS -- IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT OUR FBI HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED AND THAT AMERICAN
CITIZENS HAVE BEEN TARGETED FOR
SURVEILLANCE FOR PURELY
POLITICAL REASONS OR THAT THE
OBAMA JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
MAYBE EVEN SOME OF THE
WHITE HOUSE WERE IN ON IT, BOY,
DO THE PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW?
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW NOW,
NOT SIX WEEKS FROM NOW AND NOT
SIX MONTHS FROM NOW.
REMEMBER, THIS DOSSIER WAS A
CAMPAIGN GENERATED DOCUMENT PAID
FOR BY THE DEMOCRATS.
IT WAS USED TO JUSTIFY SPYING ON
ANYONE ASSOCIATED WITH
DONALD TRUMP, HEADS SHOULD ROLL.
IT’S TIME TO EXPOSE THIS ENTIRE
CIRCUS TO THE SUNLIGHT.
ALL OF US SHOULD BE ABLE TO
TRUST FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
BE OBJECTIVE AND NOT FILLED WITH
SOME VENGEFUL POLITICAL HACK DO